and I guess how how do you kind of put
somebody like let's take Elan musk for
example right who's been involved in
various capacities and a number of
innovative things some of which he was
the founder right or kind of the
equivalent of the inventor and then some
of which like a Tesla where somebody
else actually came up with the idea he
stepped in yes he has the title of
founder but really he helped kind of
commercialize and scale the technology
what I'm interested in for somebody like
that is you can do it once and kind of
back into something you know get lucky
to do whatever you want to call it to do
it over and over and over again appears
to be a skill right or some sort of
experience at play there and it's ok how
does that fit into the framework where
those people are very rare right so
they're definitely exception in society
but how do you kind of evaluate somebody
who can kind of repetitive
well obviously people who can do that
over and over again extraordinarily
talented and they they they show an
ability to to learn from their
experience that is absolutely vital you
know it's I mean someone like Thomas
Edison did this again and again and
again he set up an innovation Factory
the job of which was to produce
innovations and he made lots of people
work for him and work very hard and he
told them to do lots of trial and error
experiments and he got results and that
is certainly a key result but it I don't
think it comes from a particular spark
of genius I think this is where we go
wrong we tend to look at people like
that and think well I could never do
that because I'm not as clever as Elon
Musk or Thomas Edison but actually the
secret sauce that these guys bring is
hard work persistence tolerance of
failure ability to learn from their
mistakes Elon Musk has certainly made
mistakes is his solar companies
got into trouble etc it's not the jury's
still out on Tesla I mean it's hugely
dependent on government grants and
things like that and I say in my book
that I think his ideas of the Hyperloop
are probably extremely impractical so
you know it's not the case that
everything they do is brilliant and I
think it's quite important to get away
from that to stop trying to put these
people on a pedestal and make them into
gods and say that what you know they
were partly lucky in the right place at
the right time
partly persistent a huge amount of sort
of pigheaded obstinacy can be helpful
but not so pigheaded Lee obstinate that
you don't change course when the facts
change that's the other thing and they
were prepared to put in the hours that's
Thomas Edison's remark about
perspiration not inspiration etc so in a
sense I'm trying to demystify these
godlike figures now I'd do it by telling
stories in my book I tell a lot of
stories about how innovations came to be
and I often focus on the key individual
who was involved but I'm not trying to
make them into the author of it I'm
trying to make them into the the subject
of it almost the person to whom this
phenomenon happened and I'm also trying
to put them in the social context of the
other people they relied upon I love
that and so for those that are listening
who say great I don't have to be some
you know wonder kid genius in order to
to participate in this kind of
innovation arc what can they do to
become more innovative right as you've
kind of studied so many of these stories
are there things that people can
actually do to kind of practice or or
develop that muscle or is this something
that is more just trial and error and go
try to solve problems and it'll come to
you as you kind of put those hours in
well I don't really know the answer to
that question because I'm not I'm not in
the business of training people in
anything and probably would be very bad
at it if I was and I'm not much of an
innovator myself unless you call a book
and
innovation but I think one thing that it
might be worth passing on is the growth
of something called free innovation so
what this refers to and my friend Andrew
Torrence who's a professor of economics
and other things in Kansas explains has
explored this very much it's it's the
user the consumer making adjustments to
technologies to make them more useful
and then sharing them and so a very nice
example of this is the system called
Knight Scout which is used by parents to
monitor the sugar status of their
diabetic kids in school and essentially
it's about you know the the the the the
real-time data being uploaded to a
network where parents can can keep an
eye on it and this was entirely built by
two or three parents one of whom did one
part of it one of him did another part
of it third added a third layer and so
on and changed the name it you know it
starts out with it with a gadget from a
pharmaceutical company but the the whole
superstructure of the sort of the the
internet interface with with this device
was built by users and is now made
available through a foundation to any
parent who's in the same situation the
surfboard industry learns a lot from its
users apparently the users make make
adjustments to the shapes and devices on
surfboards and feeds these back to the
manufacturers so I think it's and by the
way there's you know obviously patents
can get in the way of this kind of thing
but shouldn't because actually the law
is if you if you do this and you change
something and it's your own creation
then you can't be stopped from doing it
so it's quite important I think to think
about the fact that you in the way you
adjust and adapt any old device are you
of being an innovator and all you've got
to do is feed that to other people in a
small way and suddenly you're a
innovative businessperson